sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsables se cumplen
tres meses desde que inició la invasión
de rusia a ucrania tras una campaña
fallida en el norte las tropas rusas se
han replegado y han concentrado sus
esfuerzos en el este y en el sur del
país tomando total control del puerto de
mariupol y logrando significativos
avances en bombas donde el presidente
excelencia ha calificado la situación
con un verdadero infierno en la
provincia de luhansk las tropas de moscú
buscan rodear la ciudad del issys jones
pero también y especialmente
severodonezk una urbe que está siendo
totalmente destruida por los constantes
bombardeos nuestros enviados especiales
catalina gómez ángel y mickeal konaté
estuvieron con los hombres que defienden
los tres pueblos de los que ucrania
todavía mantiene el control al este de
severodonezk son atacados
permanentemente y se cree que si caen
esta podría ser la vía para que moscú se
tome definitivamente la ciudad
el comandante ya no tiene a su cargo una
las posiciones de las fuerzas ucranianas
al este de la ciudad de severodonezk
el último ataque fue hace unas horas
atacaron la posición vecina los atacaron
con bombas racimos con todo lo que
quisieron
las tropas rusas están en el bosque a
menos de un kilómetro
bien
es así
la batalla por severodonezk y la
provincia a luján que es la más intensa
que se libra actualmente en ucrania esta
es una de las tres poblaciones al oeste
de cebrones que todavía permanecen en
control de los ucranianos para ellos son
fundamentales porque de llevarlas a
perder la ciudad quedaría prácticamente
encerrada
las tropas rusas atacan sin cesar estas
poblaciones cientos de integrantes del
ejército de moscú que han sido
expulsados en las últimas semanas de
otras regiones de ucrania pelean en este
frente y ahora todas las fuerzas rusas
se están trasladando a este territorio
es muy difícil es muy complicado
utilizan tanques pero especialmente la
artillería como estrategia para doblegar
a la defensa ucraniana como resultado
van dejando poblaciones destruidas y
muchas veces arrasadas
el comandante andrés tiene a su cargo la
defensa de otra posición hay un gran
riesgo al estar en este pueblo han
atacado en frente de la casa atacaron la
casa de los vecinos están tratando de
destruir todo por completo ellos ven un
asentamiento y su objetivo es destruirlo
aquí todos tienen que permanecer bajo
techo los drones rusos sobrevuelan
haciendo trazados sobre el terreno
este es el cuarto de operaciones su
estrategia disuadir al enemigo y no
darle la oportunidad de atacar
para esto se apoyan en las nuevas armas
enviadas por países occidentales como
esta lanzadera
[Música]
en los bosques donde los tanque y el
equipo pesado del enemigo no puede pasar
tenemos menos pero en otros terrenos
abiertos con mayor amenaza hay más y
todos los hombres saben ahora cómo
usarlos y
[Música]
reconocen que la llegada de este
armamento ha elevado la moral aún así
saben que esta es una de las batallas
más difíciles
rusia tiene superioridad aérea y ahora
enfoca toda su fuerza en tomar el
control de severodonezk
el metro de la ciudad de jarque se ha
convertido en uno de los lugares más
emblemáticos de esta guerra en el este
del país tres meses después de la
invasión rusa centenares de personas
continúan viviendo allí bajo tierra y
algunos han llegado desde las aldeas
donde en estos momentos se libran los
combates más intensos las enviadas
especiales de france 24 a leticia
álvarez e irene sabio lo visita
sus rostros dieron la vuelta del mundo
cuando estalló la guerra en ucrania casi
tres meses después centenares de
personas siguen viviendo en el metro
subterráneo de jarquín
resisten porque tienen miedo y no tienen
a donde ir
larissa tiene 61 años y un padre de 85
años que no se puede mover está leyendo
una novela cuando la encontramos
leer me ayuda a no pensar en lo que
ocurre afuera me distraigo de esta
manera aquí
es un sitio silencioso en casa es
imposible
allí empiezas a leer y empiezan las
explosiones
lina es otro rostro de esta vida bajo
tierra es una de las tantas personas de
los pueblos cerca de jarquín donde los
combates entre rusia y ucrania se
intensificaron en esta fase de la guerra
llegué de derecha y el 4 de abril a
principios de la guerra se podía estar
en mi casa entonces los bombardeos no
eran tan fuertes
pero luego se volvió imposible dormir me
escapé saliendo del patio trasero de mi
casa y me vine hasta aquí
[Música]
en jarque queda sólo el 20% de la
población es realmente impresionante ver
a estas personas durmiendo aquí en el
suelo resistiendo son los que no se han
podido o no se han querido ir de esta
ciudad victoria- estudia con su hija
catherine ha decidido no dejar archivos
a pesar de que la niña sólo tiene 11
años no no me quiero ir pienso que
ganaremos me quiero quedar hasta el
final
clarisa lina victoria y la pequeña
ekaterina son uno de los símbolos de la
guerra en ucrania una humanidad que se
ha tenido que esconder para no perder la
vida
en las primeras semanas de la guerra las
tropas rusas rodearon y atacaron la
ciudad de charney y una urbe del norte
de ucrania que representaba ante todo un
obstáculo en el objetivo final que era
llegar aquí a la capital está misión
rusa fracasó debido al éxito que
tuvieron las fuerzas aéreas ucranianas
con el derribo de numerosos aviones
rusos evitando que esta ciudad pudiera
recibir daños más graves pero con
trágicas consecuencias para muchos de
sus residentes el siguiente es un
informe de gulliver' crank y ride
abusaíd
cinco casas en cherney hiv fueron
destruidas el 5 de marzo y un residente
murió cuando las fuerzas ucranianas
derribaron un bombardero ruso julia red
nueva diputada local estaba en el sótano
de su refugio en ese momento con cuatro
niños
bajamos al sótano el 5 de marzo solo
para ordenar cambiar las sábanas y
sucedió sólo un par de minutos después
la casa comenzó a derrumbarse
más tarde vería la causa este sukoi 34
cuyos escombros aún están donde cayó
y
estaba acostada encima de los niños
tenía miedo incluso de mover no era
imposible pararme porque el techo estaba
en llamas las fuerzas de defensa
territorial junto con mi esposo nos
sacaron de ahí bastante rápido
la supervivencia de yulia parece casi
milagrosa es muy consciente de que las
cosas podrían haber sido peores
a bordo de ese avión habían cinco bombas
de 500 kilogramos o tres pero gracias a
dios no explotar
a dos cuadras de distancia se
desarrollaba otro drama los pilotos se
habían lanzado en paracaídas uno fue
asesinado el otro cayó en este patio
y
vimos el humo y que algo había caído mi
hermano decidió ir a ver qué pasaba
salió y vio que el piloto había
aterrizado aquí y corrió tras él
pero mi hermano lo persiguió hasta aquí
y justo ahí en el gallinero lo mató el
pelo
en este momento los soldados ucranianos
también llegaron a perseguirlo
y
llegamos a este galpón buscándolo y
escuchamos gritos de no disparen me
rindo entonces le ordenamos que saliera
abrió la puerta y ordenamos que se
bajara
iván quien hizo este vídeo dice que
protegieron al piloto de una multitud de
enojada bien eurogrupo respondió como le
habían indicado que no sabía nada que
estaba en una misión de entrenamiento
jr
el día anterior al derribo del avión
este edificio había sido bombardeado los
ataques aéreos sobre ser de hiv
continuaron durante dos semanas
en los frentes de batalla hay médicos
que salvan vidas pero que también se
enfrentan a la posibilidad de ser
atacados cientos de unidades médicas
apoyan a las tropas ucranianas en los
campos de combate sin embargo ese
trabajo se hace cada día más difícil y
riesgoso las ambulancias y los
hospitales siguen siendo objetivos de la
artillería y de los aviones enemigos y
nuestros enviados especiales catalina
gómez ángel y mikel cola te visitaron un
hospital de campaña en una ubicación no
revelada en la región del donbass
y ahora regresa del frente de batalla es
para médica y su vehículo es un ejemplo
de la ferocidad de los combates
la bomba cayó al lado del carro pero
nosotros estábamos en el suelo
la vida de los militares y civiles
atrapados en el conflicto depende de
cientos de integrantes del cuerpo médico
del ejército para quienes la guerra no
comenzó el 24 de febrero
durante 8 años aquí en el frente de
batalla cada mes tenemos soldados
muertos
vitaly conducción a las ambulancias que
recoge heridos de gravedad en el frente
de batalla
el actuar de los rusos ha cambiado
significativamente comparado con 2014 el
calibre de las armas ha cambiado es más
grande y más poderoso y abarca mucho más
espacio que antes
en esta nueva etapa también atacan con
insistencia a las misiones médicas los
hospitales de campaña están en lugares
secretos muchas ambulancias tapan la
cruz roja que las identifica y apagan
las luces en medio de la noche
tenemos rumores los llamamos la
frecuencia elefante y vienen del frente
de batalla esos rumores dicen que los
rusos reciben dinero adicional por
atacar unidades de transporte médico y
doctores es como una cacería
el doctor andrei borisenko tiene a su
cargo una de las unidades médicas más
experimentadas del ejército ucraniano su
misión es atender a los pacientes graves
que necesitan tratamiento médico urgente
los estabilizan y luego los tablados
hospitales militares urbanos
que hemos sido atacados varias veces y
hemos tenido que evacuar tan rápido como
se puede pero nuestro trabajo es estar
aquí tenemos que salvar vidas
este paciente se volcó en su vehículo
cuando huía de un ataque la mayoría de
las personas que atienden en este
hospital sufren de traumas
el doctor andrew se reintegró al
ejército desde el primer día de la
guerra en esta sala de cirugía
improvisada los doctores dicen que sus
llamados cuidar de quienes ponen la vida
en riesgo por defender a los ucranianos
su labor es tan importante que las
fuerzas rusas intentan desmoralizar los
y eliminarlos pero en este objetivo
tampoco han tenido éxito
queremos agradecer aparcadero por
prestarnos sus instalaciones para grabar
nuestro programa ya ustedes también
muchas gracias por seguir un nuevo
episodio de corresponsales nos vemos la
próxima semana siga con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom